hello everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel and today I am catching up on
the Last of Us official teaser on the
HBO Maxi YouTube channel this came out
earlier this week and I haven't watched
it yet but I've been very excited to
catch up on it um also I'm super nasally
and I probably look like trash because
I'm a bit sick today
um but yeah it's interesting I went from
initially being like
I don't even feel the need to have a new
last of a show why would I need that the
game's already so good I'm so excited
about part one I don't feel like I need
to see this universe again
um but I think some of the Whispers that
have come from set
I've sort of changed my mind on that and
now I am pretty excited about it what I
hope for this teaser is that it doesn't
just look like a rehash of the game I
actually don't want it to be the same
thing I know a lot of fans love things
being identical but I would just play
the game the first game is still
especially now with part one it's still
so so so good it holds up so well that I
hope this looks different enough
um that I'm still in for some surprises
and and some some story beats that maybe
you know people have already played the
game unexpecting so that's what I'm
looking for uh let's watch it it's only
a minute and 48 seconds
I'm excited
[Music]
the roses have faded there's Frost at my
door the birds in the morning don't sing
anymore
[Music]
darkness is falling in the sky that's
awesome
the Hound in the distance is starting to
fade
oh
the sound
oh Lord if you hear me please
[Music]
[Music]
and you said everything right
God
to say who you can say
oh please understand hmm
so
I wasn't expecting the Left Behind
storyline to show up the it's so good
and so sad
choose your plan shut up
um okay so obviously this is very much a
teaser I feel like I maybe expected a
little more story content than they ever
would have even hoped to putting in here
um and it is very much a teaser
you don't really get a lot of story info
just a lot of shots of like uh I'm so
close to that or is it did think that
looked very cool the hearing the click
is in live action
I wonder how scary it's gonna be and
obviously this is supposed to appeal to
audiences audiences who've never played
the license as well
so I'm wondering like it's hard to
remove myself from it because I'm
looking so hard for video game
references or like things that I know
and understand I wonder how appealing
this trailer is to people who've never
played The Last of Us or even people who
aren't gamers
because it doesn't look
super different from your usual zombie
apocalypse
TV show and movie if you're just talking
about the trailer
um
I love the variety of environments
though
and like it's it is just nice to see
that they're actually going through all
the seasons obviously
with uh winter and everything in there
yeah so my biggest takeaway is this
looks really good the shots are great it
looks like it's very well made none of
that surprises me I didn't really get
anything other than that but that's
probably on me for expecting more than
just a teaser when it literally says to
teaser and let's see what the internet
had to say about it
The Game of Thrones references of course
Pedro's making career being the most
badass babysitter of all time that's
definitely true
my oh my this looks like a serious
production what I mean by that is it
just looks like they're really trying to
do well by the game which is a
masterpiece I guess yeah I mean it
definitely looks like a serious
production it's HBO I expected that I
don't know how much of the game's gonna
be in it or not
I love that some of the shots are
exactly the same as the game definitely
the show itself seems to carry the same
atmosphere and those shots just made it
stronger kind of pumped to see this the
whole teaser is so atmospheric
especially this shot where the Fallen
buildings are eliminated by lightning
strongly agree that was very cool
earlier during my last this walkthrough
I thought that no one could play the
role of Joel better than Hugh Jackman
yeah Hugh Jackman probably could have
done a good job
but now I see Pedro Pascal I'm convinced
he does look very good as Joel very very
good as Joel
it's like it I didn't initially see it
when they announced the costing but like
you know seeing him with the Scruff and
I guess it was hard to separate him from
manalore and being that that was so
recent but
Pedro admits such Joel Vibes he really
does yeah it's very very good
so it seems like people are pretty
excited but I also feel like YouTube
comment sections tend to pump the
positive stuff up to the top
not sure if anyone noticed but this song
in the trailer alone and forsaken by
Hank Williams was also featured in the
game both original and the remastered
re-release I didn't know that
for once I actually have a bit of faith
in a video game TV show it looks good
and Pedro is surprisingly but fitting
actor
for Joel I totally agree
it does look good there are definitely
some shots that are literally from
the game which is really cool
um yeah I now I'm mostly curious about
how it differs
I don't want it to be exactly the same
personally it might be an unpopular
opinion I would like to see some things
be different um just so that I'm not
reliving the same experience when that
experience is already so good to play
through
um especially again with part one being
so recent so
it looks really good it looks like they
care a lot which is important we've had
so many like
Hollywood Video Game adaptations where
they just throw everything out because
they don't care about anything other
than money I don't feel like that is the
case here I feel like clearly the team
at naughty dog cares clearly HBO makes
very good quality products and this
really suits the stuff HBO makes I think
it's a really good partnership so I'm
excited personally